hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tanten welt ich habe heute ein halloween
rezept für euch und zwar wurde ich
gefragt was man denn so auch für eine
halloween party machen könnte und ich
hab da ein bisschen im internet
recherchiert und hab da ein paar ideen
rausgeholt heute möchte ich ein paar
großen finger machen die sind dann aus
dieser abgeschnittenen finger eigentlich
total ekelhaft aber sie schmecken sehr
gut weil ich sehr aus dem marzipan tag
mache falls ihr kein marzipan möglich
könnt ihr auch einen normalen website
nehmen dafür linke hier einfach ein
rezept in der infobox
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten wir
brauchen 250 gramm mehl 125 gramm butter
200 gramm marzipanrohmasse 100 gramm
zucker 1 eine gute prise salz und ein
paar mandeln
hier habe ich jetzt schon welche
geschält und seitlich auf gleich wie man
solche mandeln schälen kann und wir
brauchen etwas konfitüre
ich habe jetzt hier sauerkirsche ich
werde den teig jetzt in einer
küchenmaschine zusammenmixen ihr könnt
ihr aber auch einfach per hand verkneten
dazu gebe ich einfach alle zutaten
gemeinsam hier rein
die smarte panzer kleiner ich ein
bisschen geht's schneller
und jetzt muss es nur vermixt werden
wenn sich die zutaten dann vermischt
haben gebe ich sie auf einer
arbeitsfläche und kann sie noch mal ganz
kurz zu einer kugel zusammen rollen und
so merkt man auch dass der teig sehr
weich ist und sehr klebrig ist und
deswegen müssen wir erst mal kühl
stellen
ich fliege jetzt in alufolie 1 in
frischhaltefolie und damit das ganze
etwas schneller geht
drücke ich den teig flach dann wird er
nämlich schneller kalt und ich stelle
ihnen jetzt für 15 minuten in den
gefrierschrank und verwenden damit in
der zwischenzeit zeige ich euch mal wie
ich die mandeln gehäutet habe und zwar
habe die mandeln drin und gebt da
abgekochtes wasser drüber und das lasse
jetzt noch fünf minuten stehen und dann
kann ich die mandeln aus der haut
einfach herausdrücken
der teig gesetze richtig schön kalt und
ich arbeite jetzt hier nur mit der
hälfte der zeit ist damit eher einfach
nicht warm wird und sobald stehen
verarbeitet die zweite hälfte in form
ich jetzt zu nahe langen rolle und die
rolle sollte dann ungefähr so dick sein
wie ihr eure finger aber ich würde eher
sagen ein bisschen dicker könnt ihr auch
noch mal mehr und der teig darf jetzt
nicht zu warm werden deswegen müssen
jetzt ein bisschen schnell arbeiten
fertig wie männer finger
und dann schneidet ihr diese rolle so
finger lang in städten ab könnte am
besten so machen
und jetzt kommen wir die finger daraus
und zwar muss vorne der eine teil
abgerundet werden
und hier würde ich jetzt zwei mal mit
dem finger so einrollen sonja bisschen
gruselig finger seien keine schönen
frauen finger deswegen dürfen die ein
bisschen hässlich aussehen
und dann schneidet ihr mit einem messer
hier noch ein paar rillen ein dass die
haut so ein bisschen verschrumpelt aus
und vorne drücken wir jetzt noch hier
die mandel rein praktisch als
fingernagel
und dann legen wir das ganze auf dem
backpapier zu sehen jetzt die finger aus
ich habe es noch nicht alles fertig
gemacht aber ich werde schon mal das
erste blech was ich fertig habe in den
kühlschrank stellen die müssen jetzt
noch mal für etwa 15 minuten gekühlt
werden so dass für sie gleich backen
können weil sie ansonsten zerlaufen
würden besser finde ich es wenn es über
nacht im kühlschrank stellt oder einfach
für eine halbe stunde oder stunde ins
gefrierfach auf jeden fall müssen sie
eiskalt sein und dann werden sie bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze für etwas zehn
minuten gebacken
sie müssen etwas hell bleiben und danach
bin und vielleicht wieder zu sehen die
grusel finger jetzt auswendig gebacken
sind und ich hab sie hier auf eine
ausgiebige tage geben sie sind nur noch
leicht lauwarm und ich hatte jetzt hier
die marmelade in den spritzbeutel
gewöhnt mit seiner fülle das braucht ihr
nicht und müsst ihr nicht könnt auch die
finger einfach in die marmelade ein
drucken oder eben mit einem kleinen
löffel da rein machen
ich nehme jetzt mir einen finger und wie
gesagt sind sie noch leicht lauwarm ihr
müsst aufpassen dass die jetzt nicht
brechen dann stecke ich das hier rein
sprit da etwas marmelade rein und zwar
so dass sie unten wieder raus läuft der
fluten
dann könnte auch ein platte setzen
und zu sehen sie dann fertig aus ich
habe hier nur ein paar angerichtet und
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr auch noch ein
schippchen marmelade daneben stellen zum
eintunken die große finger sehen zwar
total ekelhaft aus aber sie schmeckt
sehr lecker und wie gesagt gibt es die
auch in marzipan freie version wenn ihr
sie einfach mit einem normalen website
macht das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen
auf kellys blog.de das ist jetzt mein
neuer blog und da gibt's jetzt auch die
rezepte zum ausdrucken und ich freue
mich auf eure großen finger auf eure
fotos auf instagram oder facebook und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder bis bald tschüss